COMPARED PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
FAMILY TO SADDAM HUSAIN'S KIDS.
JESSICA TARLOV THE HOST OF
WATERS WORLD AND HIS WORLD WE
LIVE IN.
>> Sean: YOU'RE GOOD.
I WAS ON YOUR SHOW.
JESSICA, THERE IS A LEVEL OF
AS A LIBERAL YOU MIGHT BE
EMBARRASSED ABOUT.
>> I'M NOT REALLY THAT
EMBARRASSED WHEN YOU THINK HOW
PEOPLE INCLUDING THE PRESIDENT
TALKED ABOUT BARACK OBAMA.
HE SAID HE FOUNDED ISIS.
HE WAS A BIRTHER.
HILLARY CLINTON HAS PARKINSON'S
DISEASE, SHE SHOULD BE IN JAIL.
THAT'S COMING FROM SOMEONE WHO
ENDED UP AS THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
TALK ABOUT TED NUDGEENT INVITED
TO THE WHITE HOUSE CALLING HIM
A SUB HUMAN HMONG REAL.
>> Sean: NICELY DONE.
>> THE PRESIDENT SAID PHONY
INVESTIGATION HAS HURT THE
COUNTRY AND THERE IS STILL NO
EVIDENCE.
>> IT'S AN EMOTION BAR'SMENT TO
THE COUNTRY AND THE LEFT
CONTINUED TO EMBARRASS
THEMSELVES.
AS A STABLE GENIUS THAT HE IS,
HE HAS THIS GIFT, SEAN, WHERE
HE BRINGS OUT THE BEST IN
PEOPLE BUT HE ALSO BRINGS OUT
THE WORST IN PEOPLE AND HE HAS
DONE THAT WITH HOLLYWOOD AND
MEDIA.
DENIRO SOUNDS LIKE A SLOPPING
DRUNK HANGING OUT WITH TOM
THE SECRET SERVICE.
KATHY GRIFFIN IS BEHEADING
PEOPLE AND THE MEDIA THE SAME
THING.
PEOPLE ARE GETTING TIRED FOR
TANKING THE STOCK MARKET AND
SUED FOR SLANDER.
SO HE HAS THIS ABILITY WHERE
HIS ENEMIES DESTROY THEMSELVES.
THEY ARE SCREAMING, THEY'RE
CRYING, THEY ARE WEARING THE
PINK LITTLE HATS.
>> Sean: I KNOW DONALD TRUMP.
I'VE KNOWN HIM LONG BEFORE HE
RAN FOR PRESIDENT.
HE IS A FUNNY GUY.
AND HE DOES THIS OKAY, YOU WANT
SOME FUN.
EVERYBODY EXPECTS HE IS GOING
TO ONE DAY WAKE UP AND SAY OH,
I'M GOING TO BE EXACTLY -- I'M
GOING TO BOW AND KISS THE RING
OF THE MULLAHS IN IRAN.
IT IS NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
DOLLARS AND BEG THEM TO LIKE US.
THAT'S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
THAT'S NOT WHO THE AMERICAN
THE ECONOMY IS UP.
>> STANDING UP TO MUR DEARING
DICTATORS IS GOOD.
I DON'T DO THAT IMITATION AS
WELL AS YOU CAN.
I JUST -- I HAVE TO SAY TO YOU
GUYS SITTING HERE REMOTE WHICH
MAKES THIS MORE DIFFICULT AND
LISTENING TO YOU TALK ABOUT ALL
THE LIBERAL CRY BABIES WHEN
CONSERVATIVES WERE UP IN ARMS
IF PRESIDENT OBAMA WORE A TAN
SUIT.
IT IS RIPE WITH HYPOCRISY.
>> EVERYBODY AGREES IT WAS A
TERRIBLE SUIT.
>> I LIKED THAT SUIT A LOT,
JESSE.
>> Sean: WHAT DID OBAMA DO ON
THE ECONOMY?
NAME ONE STATISTIC WHERE YOU
SAY OBAMA DID A GREAT JOB HERE.
>> THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO GOT
HEALTH INSURANCE BECAUSE OF
OBAMACARE.
100%.
>> Sean: HOW ABOUT WHO HAD TO
PAY EIGHT TIMES.
WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT?
HASN'T CONDEMNED HARVEY
WEINSTEIN BUT HE IS OUT THERE
RIPPING TRUMP.
SO WE KNOW WHERE HIS PRIORITIES
ARE.
DENIRO LIVES IN L.A.
LITTLE ROCK ETMAN HAS MISSILES
FURY RHETORIC NOW THE NORTH HAS
COME TO THE TABLE AND STARTED
TALKING TO THE SOUTH.
I THINK A LOT OF THE STUFF HE
GETS CRITICIZED FOR.
THEY DON'T LIKE HIS STYLE BUT
LOOK AT THE RESULTS.
HE DEFEATED ISIS, HE HAS THE
STOCK MARKET -- ECONOMY IS
SAYS.
HILLARY COULDN'T BEAT AN IDIOT.
WHAT DOES THAT MAKE HER?
>> THE MOST QUALIFIED PERSON TO
RUN FOR THE PRESIDENCY IN A
LONG TIME IS WHAT HILLARY
CLINTON IS AND I'M CURIOUS IF
THE THINGS THAT DONALD TRUMP
SAID ABOUT PRESIDENT OBAMA OR
HILLARY CLINTON WERE SAID BY
PRESIDENT --
>> Sean: DOES IT BOTHER YOU THE
HILLARY BOUGHT AND PAID FOR
PHONY RUSSIAN PROPAGANDA
DOSSIER WAS USED TO OBTAIN A
FISA WARRANT AS WE ARE
REPORTING TONIGHT?
>> I DID SEE THE SEGMENT AND I
NEED TO SPEND MORE TIME WITH
THAT BEFORE I GO WITH THAT.
IT DOES NOT SEEM TO ME THAT
SAYING THAT THAT IS THE CASE.
THERE IS NO SMOKING GUN HERE.
>> Sean: THERE IS.
THE HOUSE INTEL COMMITTEE HAS
IT ALL.
>> I GUESS WE'LL FIND OUT.
>> SHE PAID FOR FAKE DIRT FROM
THE RUSSIANS THAT STARTED THE
WIRETAPPING?
THAT'S THE PRETTY BIG STORY.
>> I DIDN'T SAY IT WASN'T A BIG
STORY.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT HANNITY IS
>> I'M SAYING I SAW --